Your 20s aren't what you think they are.
That perfectly filtered path others seem
to be taking. It's just a highlight
reel, not reality. The greatest freedom
of your 20s isn't having it all figured
out. It's realizing nobody does. We're
fed this narrative of checking boxes by
certain ages, career by 23, relationship
by 25, house by 28. But behind those
Instagram posts, everyone's
experimenting, failing, and feeling
exactly like you do, uncertain. I've
talked with hundreds of people in their
30s and 40s about their 20s. None said,
"I wish I'd had my life more figured
out. Instead, they wish they'd worried
less and understood that the winding
path is the path. Your 20s are about
unlearning the myth that you should have
it all figured out, creating an identity
laboratory to discover who you are, and
building relationships that help you
grow, not just exist.